hi everyone I'm here again with James my
friend who you may remember from our
videos about physics horror stories we
did undergrad together and we seem to
have a lot of these horror story type
you know memories from a physics degree
and I thought it would only be complete
and fair to make a good memories version
otherwise we're presenting a very skewed
view of the physics degree but I sort of
struggled to come up with good memories
and we've had a discussion already about
some memories we've sort of been
wracking our brains to think of things
and I don't know if this is because
there are inherently less good memories
than bad ones from a degree or if the
bad memories are just really funny yeah
I tend to enjoy like fails and and and
failing like as my good memory laughing
at those times or if maybe it's a
psychological thing where you remember
traumatic experiences more than good
ones cuz the good ones just posture
topped in for the girls 20 okay top 10
physics fails not clickbait so we have
managed to come up with some things so
we'll talk about some of our stories I
think we'll go through an order from
like first year upwards and these are
some of our more positive physics
stories for any of you aspiring physics
majors out there alright so the first
time I have that I want to talk about
was in a first year math course we had
quite a cool lecturer who decided to go
but artsy on the math so she said well
here's some chalk go out somewhere in
the university and draw one of the
concepts we've been learning about in
class I like draw a big you know chalk
illustration of it and then like the
best one wins a prize like post a photo
of the best one so I remember the one
that we did like it was just the two of
us with him together
I think if I remember rightly it was
about the day before the lecture where
she was going to hand out the prizes and
we're procrastinated and not done
anything because we're very last-minute
people so I remember it started raining
we're thinking ah no rain short
is not gonna work oh yeah yeah I
remember it's like we're like oh we
can't draw our chalk illustration in the
rain this is not a good idea but on the
other hand we were like but she's gonna
hand out the prizes tomorrow and if you
don't do it no you're not gonna win a
prize so we took care of chalk out in
the rain and yeah I do remember walking
around and finding like one dry spot on
campus it was like an overhang building
and years like a small spot of cement on
the ground that wasn't wet that's
perfect and we drew something that
represented the Taylor series the Taylor
series of a sine wave Taylor series of a
sine wave like we called it tailoring
polynomials and we drew like a big like
suit like that you'd wear and like a
needle and thread as I'm like tailoring
the suit we had some fun going on we had
like the thread coming off the suit was
waving in a sine wave and we had like
the Taylor series for a sine wave
following that yeah and I think I have
that picture somewhere I may try to find
it look like I said to you my pictures
and organize and that was pretty good
like we we had some fun out there being
you know putting our mouths on public
display and we won a prize the next day
specifically because it was dedication
to mathematics for going out in the rain
and writing chalk on ground yeah yeah we
won a prize we want a bag of lollies
that I like gave away to our friends but
immediately want them but I also
remember that because this had been the
only dry spot in the rain it was like a
really rainy day that actually for a
really long time after this it was still
there like everyone else's paintings
like washed away
ours was just still there for at least
like I don't know the month or something
afterwards yeah it was a pretty long
time because it was literally in the one
place on campus that never gets wet so
it just never got washed away and it was
just like a public menace to everyone on
campus probably thinking what the hell
is this it's no sort of a pleasant
memory that was first year first year is
also when we doomed astronomy
back when we were budding astronomers
who are gonna go into the Astronomy
field and learn all about stars yeah
yeah in first year astronomy basically
the overview astronomy 101 essentially
was learning about all different corners
of the universe so we learned about star
formation and even star death and how
supernovas happen and that supernovas
are actually just the entire star
collapsing in on itself and about half a
second and then all of that matter just
bouncing back out and that's what the
supernova is just this massive balance
effectively and we also learnt about the
sort of history of the universe going
back into galaxies and early galaxies
yeah that was quite a cool course
because unlike something like first year
physics where they don't do any of the
cool stuff they just like here is a
slope here's a ball rolling down the
slope do this for an entire semester
here is a box on the slope does it slide
maybe it slides a sliding spot how many
Newtons does it take to hold the box
like that first-year physics courses are
very mundane but the first-year Astro
course they are actually like you know
here this is all of the cool stuff in
the field here as the supernovas here is
like starfish like it was just the cool
stuff so that was a nice course yeah and
probably a good memory that one yeah
moving on into our second year memories
this was an ill-fated experiment from
one of our lecturers there seems to be
this trend I've seen in lectures where
the lecturer wants to make it
interactive they might have read some
research or something that says you know
if you get your students participating
more in the class they learn better I
feel like that was the theory behind
this but the lecturer was like ok guys
welcome to your math class I'm gonna put
a link up on the board everyone with
smartphones just like everyone go on
this link you'll basically get into a
chatroom and I'm this is a place where
you can ask questions of me while I'm
writing notes on the board doing this
like linear algebra stuff you can ask
questions live questions and I'll answer
them as I'm doing the lecture you know
like post all your problems up here and
of course everyone just immediately
logged
and you started saying the most
randomest off-topic things like people
were just sort of having a conversation
on the chat board just coming up on a
projector while the professor was
writing no yeah it was projected at the
front of the room really large so you
know it was the idea was that she would
see the questions as they come in and as
she's writing but really what happened
was that we were communicating with the
rest of the chorus of the class
anonymous a giant chat room anonymously
from our seats so like that was actually
a hilarious day and just so ill-fated
yeah I think at some point she saw the
board was a little bit horrified and I
guess long story short we never had that
happen in a lecture again I I guess she
thought she could trust us but even at
you know it's someone anonymity and
being able to post comments that are
displayed to a large number of people
and you're going to have go to chaos
yeah another second-year story and to be
fair I don't know if this quite
qualifies to be in the good memories
list this is more of a fail that I
remember fondly because I was laughing
about it but at the time it it was you
know I guess not the most pleasant so
this was I think second year physics
laughs yeah we're doing something with
lasers you remember exactly what we're
doing I don't quite so this is a fairly
typical laser experiment it's fairly
easy to perform
it's basically frequency doubling where
you take a neodymium laser which is at
1064 nanometers and you shine it into a
crystal called KTP and that quantum
magic frequency doubles the laser from
1064 nanometers to 512 which is right in
the visible region it's very bright
green yes you change the color of the
laser light yes process and it's a
pretty cool lab that things mean a
little bit wrong so we were like in a
dark room and like a group of maybe like
five or six people yeah about that and
it was a very fiddly lab so I think we
had like three hours or something to be
in this little room fiddling with tiny
little die
- like a line the laser just right
because it when it when it was perfectly
aligned it would do this like frequency
doubling it would change color and we
were waiting for that to happen we were
just like in there arranging things so
to sort of set the scene you have to
imagine a pitch-black room with a 1064
nanometer laser which is in the infrared
so you can't see this laser at all and
it's completely dark so you can barely
see what you're a mia and you try and
just make micro adjustments to get this
very invisible laser pointed at this
very very small crystal and so we'll
only know that we've done it correctly
when we see the laser you know come out
on the other side and when you see this
green light coming out we might come out
inside and I think the thing is that
infrared laser is dangerous like to your
eyes so you're wearing safety goggles so
yeah and because because they're safety
goggles they need to block out infrared
which means they're actually green
tinted yeah so that means that um I
guess there were many many hours of
fiddling for dials and saying to each
other we just can't get it to work yep
and then eventually someone was like I
can't see anything with these goals I'm
gonna take them off take them off in the
new meters is what's that thing on the
wall there's a green or more like what
no no it can't see anything and then
everyone takes off their green glasses
and suddenly they can see a green dot on
the wall and everyone's cheering
positivity has erupted and we realized
that the owls we spent fiddling and like
being like why isn't it working I wasn't
working is because we literally could
not see the laser light was the color of
glasses that we had chosen to use so it
was a fail but it's you know having that
relief and like funny outcome after
hours and trauma and struggle just makes
it you know a good memory enjoyable
variable thing like a funny story and
yeah so that was like a fun time because
we were in a group in like we could make
light of the situation and I think it's
actually a segue also into my next point
which is like most of
the good memories and a physics degree
are to do with the people I was doing it
with and like the friends so I I mean I
I feel like I only have good memories
because of the friends I was with so
working together on assignments and
group projects those projects became fun
because of the people I was doing it
with specifically even those really
difficult tedious projects that take you
up into the early hours of the morning
but then when you finally have that
finished out and everyone sort of
understands the assignment now you've
got all of the writing done and it's
written up nicely and it makes sense and
it's satisfying the relief of
understanding it of being completed yeah
and I think like I have a lot of good
memories of sort of us and a few others
working late at night maybe at uni on
these assignments to get them to that
final stage in front of a whiteboard
just arguing with you the other day this
is how you do the equation no no we do
it this way no this will be easy
and then someone grabs a pin they're
like no no no this I know I've got it
I've had a revelation I know how to do
it and then they do it we're still
arguing but then we'll let go and get
food or something yeah go grab some food
bring it back to the whiteboard and
continue the arguing so yeah like the
the group aspect of doing this made made
me have a lot of memories which I guess
are not directly relevant to physics but
were like a vital part of my physics
degree experience another one of the
most valuable parts of the physics
degree in terms of getting enjoyable
memories out of it is actually what you
do in between semesters or as like a
research project so often you will have
opportunities to do like internships and
summer research projects somewhere and
you actually you know get to forget
about exams and assignments and just
work on a project often that you've
chosen set something you're interested
in for a summer and those are really
valuable so I did a summer research
project when I was still studying in New
Zealand here at Anu which is where I've
ended up like doing honours and PhD
and that was an enjoyable experience
because I was you know with a bunch of
people that I like minded and we have
like a lot of social activities and
we're all researching things were really
interested in lots of discussions about
interesting research and it's like your
first taste of I guess that kind of
academic life but you're taking there
very slowly it's totally enjoyable you
sort of stepping out of the book working
into the real world
yeah anything that doesn't involve like
the stress of exams just leads to a much
more positive environment I think
definitely yeah yeah so what did you do
like your research projects so in my
third year I kind of had been lazy with
looking into projects
I know Toby had already applied to come
over to a Anu to do a project but I'd
lifted a bit late and one of our
professors said so we've got this summer
project with the chemical engineering
department where they're actually
working on 3d printing but they're doing
it using lasers so they need a physicist
to help and I was like so basically
there are lasers and 3d printing
involved that sounds pretty cool I'm
going to go for that and one of the
tasks that I had to do was actually
modeling the laser going through our
solution as it tried to print something
and sort of just looking at the solution
heating up so basically solving the heat
equation throughout time as the lasers
moving through this is my first time
sort of mathematical modeling and it was
quite a bit of a challenge it was really
difficult but after about a week of just
playing with this model I finally
managed to get this animation of this
bright laser coming through and you
could see the solution heating up around
it and then that laser would travel and
you could see like the heat as like a
wave moving forwards as the laser
traveled and sort of tailoring back as
it started to cool off and after all
that sort of hours of hard work and just
sort of pulling my hair out trying to
play with the code I had just you know a
really a really nice image that looked
really cool a this is actual physics
yeah I think it's that sort of center
section again like I've actually doing
something that was really difficult
and then you're seeing it in its final
form or like in a satisfying state your
it makes sense and you feel like you've
done good work I think a lot of people
that study physics do it for that you
know feeling at the end of doing
something that that they understand and
that they're proud of yeah yeah yes I
think that's why it's really good to try
and like get into doing some research
because otherwise you might not get to
see some of this like actual physics and
action you just doing exams and you
might be planning to do a PhD and if you
never do any research before then you
might think physics is boring it's all
exams I don't want to do a PhD or you
might get to a PhD and then you think
I've never done research before I don't
actually like this and I want to leave
yeah yeah I'd agree so like I actually
even did some astronomy like internships
at the end of second year I did one here
and like I have memories from that of
staying up like all night observing like
on a telescope and that's the kind of
experience that someone like me would
really enjoy you know you're interested
in physics and astronomy but you only
get it by applying for things like
internships and research projects so
yeah I'd really recommend them for
someone looking to make some good
memories some of our good memories that
aren't related directly to coursework
come through like the physics society
like sock and just like the community
that formed around being a physics major
so I mean I did a lot of like physics
society stuff and one of my like good
memories from all that was just our
really availability of liquid nitrogen
to do basically whatever we wondered
with it so what did we do like ice cream
and staffing yeah making ice cream using
liquid nitrogen just handing it out to
students thing like yeah join up to
physics or kept some ice cream yeah we
just seemed to have a lot of liquid
nitrogen around to you know do things
and all you're telling you before they
couldn't be disposed of it yeah so our
great plan and food stock was to attract
students by showing them really cool
stuff so like we'll get some liquid
nitrogen and we'll just pour it on the
grass and make this really cool puff of
smoke and that'll attract all the
students to the back oh what's that that
looks really cool then we get there we
pour some liquid nitrogen onto the grass
and then there's a big
puff of smoke and then all the students
I can go I know there's a big puff of
smoke quickly let's run away and then
suddenly would have no students around
us no and so they would leave and then
once the puff of smoke clears they'd be
a problem dead Brown did very frozen for
us I think we killed a lot of grass as
students I have no one from our uni is
watching this okay there might be
I hope the grass is growing back now
which is why ethics is actually
important in physics yeah so that was a
good memory and something else you
mentioned from like from the physics
society was that night they ran of like
bad science yeah so during my honours
year we did this sort of presentation
night where similar to when you're doing
a third year or fourth year projects
you're expected to give a talk in front
of the class and some of the professor's
basically what this was was instead of
giving a talk on our research we gave a
talk on just the most pseudoscience
topics we can think of so some of the
popular topics were things like crystal
healing and quantum meditation and other
just sort of buzzword assigned
scientific things that make absolutely
no sense that people would just sort of
stand up and talk about and be as
outlandish as possible yeah I like to
have a like room of physics majors
talking about that stuff and acting very
serious was it seems like a very good
idea yeah yeah like I said there are
some good memories scattered in amongst
the horror stories we don't want to
mislead you to that
yeah thanks James for being in another
one of my videos yeah give me some
stories and reminding me of things yeah
see you guys next time
you